my name is charlie baker i'm an artist
and builder and i create mostly by
weaving materials found in nature
a lot of what i create i strive to make
it look as though it could have grown
that way
combining natural materials in the most
organic way possible
[Music]
she's out of frame there she's in the
frame
there she is let's see where she goes
she's going under the wood rack and
we'll see her for a while
where were we going um your favorite
aspect of the process oh yeah
at first i just really enjoyed the
process of foraging taking beach walks
or walking through the woods and
recognizing certain shapes that spoke to
me and it wasn't until i started playing
with
some of these materials that i realized
i
was good at it and it was something i
wanted to keep doing
with some projects you start with the
drawing and you find the materials later
sometimes the design process just starts
with playing with the material you know
you want to use and seeing how it fits
together
and the overall form kind of takes shape
just from a little experimenting
sometimes the material selection
has to serve various purposes both an
aesthetic purpose if it's a piece that's
going to be outside and needs to be rot
resistant there are certain species that
are going to last longer and sometimes
you have the freedom to just pick a
material based on the aesthetic based on
what shapes or colors or textures are
appealing to you
i tend to gravitate towards twistier
more curvy shapes i feel like when
they're put together they create a sense
of motion in the final piece
there are certainly days where things
are falling into place and you find that
rhythm
and it's very enjoyable when you cut a
piece or or or bend a piece just right
and it fits right in there
it can be very easy and enjoyable and
exciting but there are certainly days
where
you feel like you're fighting a little
bit sometimes you just need to take a
break and take a break from the material
or the project because it can be a very
tedious process and and if you're not
enjoying it sometimes it can translate
into the final project so um
okay i would say my favorite most
exciting part of the process when i
reach that tipping point where you can
just
sort of see that your original vision is
coming to life it's hard not to just
sort of stop and and admire it even
though it's not quite done
my largest piece i've created was a
series of human-sized bird nests that
were roughly 10 to 12 feet diameter and
there are three of them total connected
with bridges
my favorite work memory would be working
on the nests and feeling like i was part
of a community of nesters because i was
surrounded by just a deafening chorus of
birds doing their work while i was
working in this grove of trees
one of the pieces i'm most proud of was
a eight foot diameter globe i made out
of mountain laurel twigs
it's a
series i want to create over time of
geometric shapes done with natural
materials currently working on a pyramid
version slightly smaller the eight foot
diameter ball was very ambitious this
time i'm going to go a little smaller
with the pyramid shape
so i use laurel a lot when i'm selecting
branch material it's not a branch it's a
shrub that grows in the understory but
it has very twiggy appearance to it
laurel is typically found in kind of
specific places where it likes the
acidity of the soil and it likes the
species of trees and it's kind of hard
to find those spots that it's likes and
it and is growing abundantly of course
my exact spots i keep top secret but
this batch came from out in eastern long
island
so
here we are in a spot that i found a few
years ago in an area of long island
where mountain laurel happens to grow
quite abundantly
mountain laurel has a natural resistance
to rot and bugs i've always been drawn
to this look of the bark and the way it
grows grows very twisty wavy seeking out
the light in a dense wooded areas where
it generally grows but it's the best rot
resistance that i know of in a sort of
branchy looking material which makes it
great for this project
generally look for ones that are mostly
dead as you can see this one has hardly
any greenery on it but we know it's not
quite dead and starting to rot because
it has just a little greenery left and
that's one that'll probably eventually
die but i'm going to get some good use
out of it instead of letting it rot here
in the woods
and that's that so when i head out into
the woods i don't really generally need
much in the way of tools i have my
loppers these will allow me to cut
pretty big material quickly and easily
they also function as a spiderweb
stopper i hold them a few inches in
front of my face because nobody likes a
solid mouth full of spider web
i have my smaller hand pruners to trim
off greenery or smaller diameter
branches and for bigger diameter
material or if it's hard to reach inside
with the loppers i have an arborist hand
saw that i bring
why is it that shape
i don't know why it would be that shape
to be honest
but every tree saw i've ever seen has
got a curve to it so
as a general rule i almost never take
things that are a thriving healthy
species i like to take things that are
abundant and not in any way going to
harm the area where i took them from so
you have a lot of criteria that needs to
be filled when you're selecting a
material
luna come on
there you go
this is my helpful assistant luna before
a piece is done she needs to do one last
quality check and make sure everything's
well screwed in and
you know
tip top
sometimes helpful sometimes not so
helpful
this is so far about two to three days
including the frame
with the globe shape the mountain laurel
that i was weaving together kind of just
kept going on as a continuous circle
almost a repeat of many circles and
different diameters
the challenge now is to
to try it where where you have to
actually turn a corner it'll be kind of
an experiment on how the material will
come together when we turn the sharp
edge
at the bottom i'm trying to make it look
as natural as possible almost like root
flare of a tree when the tree meets the
ground and at the top it's going to be
another challenge of the puzzle piecing
of all three sides coming together and
trying to make it as a perfect spire as
possible
really only the first layer of branches
are actually attached to the frame and
then most of them are either just tucked
into each other or screwed from one
piece to another
as i'm assembling it i'm using very
curvy pieces but i like the way they
kind of naturally move around each other
almost as like a braided rope or a
basket and i try to picture how they
want to be married to one another
so it's been sort of a
experiment and learn as you go to see
how the form is kind of taking its own
shape
as my experience as a woodworker there's
definitely
some engineering that comes into play
with some of the pieces i create they
can't just look pretty they have to be
sturdy for example the walls of the nest
have to serve as a safety barrier
because the nests are raised so most of
the puzzle-pieced twig creations are
fastened with thousands and screws
also always keep in mind that where the
screw isn't going to exit into place
where it's going to be visible
which is sometimes tricky
and when you're holding the piece in
with one hand and having to start the
screw it's always
fun
sometimes it'd be nice to have three
hands
i would say my
most used tool when i'm doing the puzzle
piecing of twigs is the band saw just
allows for intricate curvy cuts or
shaving little bits to get that fit just
right
sometimes it just sort of slots its way
in
and you know that's where it's going
even if it wasn't where you originally
wanted to fill it just found a home and
you knew it wanted to be there
the hardest part of
finishing it off
and filling the last bit of voids can
sometimes be the most time consuming
because you're finding you have one
destination for it to go and you want to
find that perfect piece to fit in that
spot whereas when you still have
multiple holes then you can kind of shop
around for where it where it seems to be
want to go
i would like to think that when people
see my pieces it gives them that feeling
that you get when you're out in nature
and combining that with craftsmanship
that i hope inspires people by the care
and the work that went into it that's
recognized but also has a look to it
that that maybe nature could have
created it and it could have grown that
way you know a combination of
craftsmanship and what you'd naturally
find out in nature
i obviously have an intense appreciation
for the already sculptural pieces that
that nature creates on its own and
in a way i just feel like i'm borrowing
and combining things that are already
there because i think nobody can create
these shapes better than mother nature
[Music]